her book that they made for us this is
all Becca has left a small box of
memories of her baby Hallie Ray she was
born at 1201 pm
Blue from head to toe it wasn't until
she was fully out
that that's when they started to sort of
like Panic what could have changed the
outcome for your daughter
her being born earlier
them getting
fresh eyes in that they never did
having a c-section never offered
all this and nothing it was never done
and she's paid the price for it
catastrophic mistakes yes one after the
other yes
Holly Ray wasn't the only one more than
200 families submitted evidence to a
report that found east Kent NHS
hospitals trust covered up the scale of
its feelings
what has happened in these Kent is
deplorable and harrowing we have
numerous instances of care that was not
given to the right standard the report
says Hospital Chiefs are accountable
they had the information that there were
serious failings and they were in a
position to act but they ignored the
warning signs and strenuously challenged
repeated attempts to point out problems
Tiffany's son Leo was still born
the emotional damage is is colossal it
really is colossal but I'll take some
comfort that it wasn't my fault
because all the way through all of their
apologies it's all been tainted with you
must contact us if you feel that there's
something wrong well I'm not a midwife
the reports are that Dr kirkup said the
trust's attitude behavior and toxic
stuff culture stopped it listening and
learning the truth was clearly covered
up on numerous separate occasions
and I've got no doubt that that resulted
from a desire not to face up to
uncomfortable truths for people but it's
a cruel thing to do to women and
families whose lives have been blighted
by these events the hospital trust says
it will act
these families came to us expecting that
we would care for them safely
and we failed them
we must now learn from
and act on this report
but these words will provide little
comfort
to The Grieving families
oh she's Josh is Sky News in Kent